es ist eigentlich nicht das Gefühl
sondern sind Umfragen die das belegen
gerade aus den letzten Tagen und Wochen
wir haben einen kleinen Zettel gemacht
hier wir haben eine ein
Vertrauensschwund in die Regierung in
den Bundeskanzler innerhalb von 12
Monaten von 56% rund 76 57 % auf 33 34%
in die Lösungskompetenz der im Bundestag
vertretenden Parteien in die an an die
glauben nur noch 45% der deutschen
Bevölkerung die Zahlen zur sozialen
Gerechtigkeit habe ich schon genannt
interessant ist dass im Osten dieses
ganze Bild das ist jetzt gesamt
Deutschland das im Osten dieses ganze
Bild noch wesentlich schlechter aussieht
die hohe Politik hat sich aus meiner
Sicht in eine Blase verabschiedet in den
medialpolitische Blase indem man indem
man nur noch im Selbstbezug lebt ähm
Politiker reden für Journalisten reden
nicht für das Volk ich schauen danach
wie sie in den Medien ankommen die
Journalisten geben ein
verzeichnetes Bild ich weiß mal so sagen
Verzeichnis Bild auch von der Stimmung
den Bedürfnissen der Bevölkerung das was
die Menschen draußen im Lande Willy
Brandt ja die Menschen draußen im Lande
von denen was die interessiert von denen
redet ja überhaupt gar keiner mehr und
das halte ich für ein riesiges Problem
wenn das so weitergeht und das ist jetzt
nach anderthalb Jahren ampelregierung
wenn das so weitergeht dann laufen wir
wirklich auf eine scharfe Klinge zu was
fehlt ihre Ansicht nach den Parteien was
fehlt in der Politikern Mut
Bodenständigkeit Bodenhaftung auch die
Bereitschaft mal ich habe das schon mal
schon mal erwähnt jetzt hier da wurde
doch der völlig März geschlagen weil er
von sozial Tourismus geredet hat weil es
bestimmte Gruppe unter den äh Flüchtling
aus der Ukraine gibt die nur einmal im
Monat herreisen ich bin danach an den
Busbahnhof Gefahren hier in Berlin 32
Busse von Berlin nach Kiel jeden Tag hin
und zurück ja und dann muss man auch mal
wenn man Friedrich Merz heißt hinter
seinem Wort stehen auch wenn man
angeschossen wird und sozusagen ja es
gibt so etwas wie sozialtourismus und
das betrifft bei weitem nicht alle
ukrainischen Flüchtlinge und das ist bei
weiten nicht repräsentativ aber es gibt
das genauso wie es dem Ausländer
Kriminalität innere Sicherheit das
bewegt die Menschen wenn sie mal draußen
mit denen reden ja da gibt es natürlich
viele die kommen mit dummen Risse und
dements und dummen Vorteil die man sich
wirklich nicht anhören muss aber da gibt
es viele die sind einfach besorgt und
die machen oft nur noch privat den Mund
auf weil sie wirklich das Gefühl haben
ich werde in dieser politischen
Landschaft nicht mehr repräsentiert
repräsentiert wir haben ein
repräsentanzprobleme in diesem Land
Politikern ein Rückgrat an Mut so wer
hat wenn er sagt also da würde ich sagen
ist ausgerechnet Friedrich Merz das
falsche Beispiel man hat das heute auch
in Bundestag ja wieder klar gesehen da
hat er auch Unterschiede zu Urlaub
Scholz klar gezeigt auch in die
Diskussion um die innere Sicherheit rund
um diese westernacht muss man das auch
mal sagen was gut dass er und kein wegen
der die Berliner CDU oder auch gerade
die nicht geblieben sind aber die Grund
Käse um nicht zu viel Dissonanz an der
Stelle zu erzeugen ist schon richtig
dass wir ein Vertrauensverlust in die
Politik haben und erleben und wir sehen
dass sehe ich mit großer Sorge dass es
oft so ein auseinanderfallen gibt
zwischen der Wahrheit die sozusagen im
politischen Raum diskutiert wird und dem
was die Leute zu Hause am Küchentisch am
Stammtisch im Fußballverein sagen und
das ist schon etwas was man auch
aufbrechen muss ich glaube so eine
Formate wie hier um ehrlich zu sein das
ist ja schon ziemlich nah dran
Stammtisch das ist so typisches
Politiker geworden die wenigsten
Menschen gehen heute noch an Stammtisch
ja ja
Politiker Wort für für das Volk was
irgendwie ja unkontrolliert und
emotional und ohne Kompetenz und ohne
große die können diese zu mir Nachteil
zum Skat spielen kommen ja da gibt's
sowas noch ja
drüber hinaus diese diese Politik so
abgehoben nein nein also nein die ist
nicht so abgehoben und jetzt mal ganz
ehrlich ich bin wie gesagt jetzt als
Vorstandsvorsitz aber trotzdem wir
können doch nicht den rechten Populisten
Nachreden und da über die Silvesternacht
reden hier in Berlin wo wir auch wissen
dass übrigens nicht nur in Neukölln der
Ali und der Mohammed da geschlagen haben
sondern auch in Mitte der Karl-heinz und
der Gerhardt
aber sie haben das äh ja gesagt
aber das sind ja nein das mache ich sie
ja auch nicht aber ich habe gesagt wir
dürfen den nicht nach reden machen wir
doch nur eine bodenständige Politik und
beschäftigen uns mit dem Problem der
Leute natürlich können wir über über
Friedrich Merz hat dieses böse Wort das
ist einfach ein böses Wort natürlich
gibt es immer Leute die Systeme
irgendwie ausnutzen das ist doch keine
Frage es ist auch bei Flüchtlingen so
aber als Abgeordnete war ich im
Ausschuss für wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit und Entwicklung und ich
war viel in Pakistan Afghanistan
unterwegs und ich sag ihm mal die Leute
sind das so arm dass die da verhungern
und ihre Kinder verhungern und wer will
denn den bitte dann vorschreiben wenn
die sich irgendwann auf dem Weg machen
weil sie ihre Kinder durchbringen wollen
weil die den ein schönes Leben
ermöglichen wollen dass die hierher
kommen deswegen bitte dieses Thema lasst
uns das sein lasst uns lieber über die
Probleme die die Deutschen haben ich
glaube ein Problem vielleicht ganz kurz
und lass mal nicht immer dieses Land so
schlecht reden wir sind ein Land mit
großartigen sicher sicher Heizsystem
oder sozialsicherungssystem ob es die
Rente ist ob es die Krankenversicherung
ist das suchen sie mal dass du ein
Fehler suchen eine bodenständige Politik
das haben sie auch gerade gesagt ich
möchte Ihnen allen hier in der Runde
einmal ein Beispiel zeigen unsere
Außenministerin Annalena bärburg hat
erklärt ein Beispiel genannt was sie
unter ihrer Strategie der feministischen
Außenpolitik versteht haben
und deswegen ist unsere feministische
Außenpolitik ein real-feminismus der
deutlich macht dass man sich mit den
realen Herausforderungen vor Ort
auseinandersetzen muss das heißt zum
Beispiel wenn wir ein Dorf unterstützen
was wieder aufgebaut wird in Nigeria das
ist ein Unterschied macht ob man sich
vorher fragt wer wohnt eigentlich in
diesem Dorf wenn man zum Beispiel die
Sanitäranlagen plant wenn man nach dem
Geruch geht könnte sie man am Rande des
Dorfes planen wenn man sich aber fragt
was bedeutet es für ein zehnjähriges
Kind nachts diese Sanitäranlagen zu
erreichen oder für eine Frau dann trifft
man die Entscheidung vielleicht nicht
für die Lage am Rande des Dorfes
ja das also eine Erklärung der
Außenministerin und hier gab es schon
verschiedenste Reaktionen während wir
diesen kleinen Ausschnitt gesehen haben
Herr Faßbender wir haben gerade darüber
gesprochen ist jetzt egal ob wir es
nennen der Karl-heinz oder der
Stammtisch lassen wir es einfach einmal
zusammengefasst unter bodenständiger
Politik die jeder verstehen soll ist das
für sie gerade ein Beispiel dafür das
ist für mich der reine Wahnsinn zwei
alte weise Frauen erklären den
nigerianischen Dorfbewohner wo sie ihre
Klaus bauen sollen weil das ist grüner
Kolonialismus aber reinsten Wassers
damit sprechen Sie doch in diesem Land
niemanden an damit sprechen Sie auch in
Nigeria niemanden an auch in Nigeria
sagen die was erzählen die uns ja was
wollen die da kommen die meisten Leute
jetzt und und machen bei uns Architektur
und nennen das real Feminismus also das
ist wie gesagt es gibt diese Plastik
Wort ja also ein bisschen auf Stammtisch
ist für mich das gibt's aber da gibt es
es gibt eine Kategorie Worte das sind
plastikworte das sind Floskeln die
werden fürs journalistische Publikum
werden die benutzt ja die werden nicht
die sprechen niemanden an auch zum
Beispiel das sagen wir mal übertriebene
Gendern ja ist auch so etwas damit wende
ich mich nicht ans voll weil im Volk
wollen das 80 Prozent der Leute nicht
tun oder eigentlich auch nicht hören
damit zeige ich nur ich gehöre zu einer
anderen wer ich gehöre zu dieser Politik
ich nenne das noch mal medialpolitischen
Blase in der sich mein Leben abspielt
und mein Denken bleiben wir noch mal
vielleicht kann man ja sagen wir haben
gerade über abgehobene Politik
gesprochen und diskutiert vielleicht
beschäftigt sich die Politik und ich
sage jetzt mal mit solchen
Nebenschauplätzen die eigentlich für die
Zukunft unseres Landes nicht die höchste
Priorität haben sollen weil wir nicht
abgehoben sind sondern weil wir schon in
so einer Bürokratie stecken in diesem
Land dass wir gar nicht mehr vom Boden
hochkommen und die dicken Bretter die
wir bohren müssen wie eben ich sag mal
Sicherungen der Gesundheitssysteme
Sicherung der Rentensysteme uns
eigentlich gar nicht mehr richtig
kümmern können
lassen uns auch noch mal bei der
Außenministerin gerade bleiben was ihnen
allen nämlich dadurch den Kopf ging als
wir das jetzt gerade angeschaut hat das
würde mich interessieren Herr amter was
haben sie sich gedacht haben sie viele
fühlen sich abgeholt verstehen jetzt wie
ministerische Außenpolitik besser ist
zuvor also ich fühle mich eher meiner
Haltung zu der Interpretation von Frau
bärbock zu feministische Außenpolitik
bestätigt dass das nämlich im Kern nur
ran ziehen scheinbar dann adressiert
wenn man jetzt sagt man redet dann
großmundig über Toiletten in Afrika in
Nigeria dann ist es ein schönes Thema
kann man alles machen meine halben aber
das eigentliche Kernthema z.B
feministische Außenpolitik wäre doch die
Situation im Iran gewesen wie es Frauen
dort im Moment geht man hat vorzugehen
gegen dieses Müller Regime auf die
Terroristen da ist feministische
Außenpolitik konkret da hat Frau bärbock
wochenlang geschwiegen geschworbelt und
deswegen wenn man sich dann auf solche
nebenkrieg Schauplätze
begibt dann kann das vielleicht
irgendwie im Walken Berlin Mitte
irgendwen in Jubelstürme über
feministische Außenpolitik und
realfeminismus versetzen das erreicht
aber weder den normalen Bürger noch ist
es etwas das in der außenpolitischen
Kernfrage etwas voranbringt Sie dazu
das Thema Iran ja ich sage auch es ist
für mich nicht nachvollziehbar warum man
weiß ja jetzt habe ich gesehen auch
wieder zwei deutsche Diplomaten sind ja
ausgewiesen worden ich kann das nicht
verstehen warum man mit diesem
mörderischen Müller Regime das sage ich
einfach mal so überhaupt noch Geschäfte
macht und ich kann auch nicht verstehen
warum immer noch an diesem atomvertrag
der ja da ist wir wissen jetzt die
Reichen an und zwar ganz viel und warum
reichen die an weil die irgendeine
Atombombe haben wollen unmöglichst
aber die feministische Außenpolitik das
ist jetzt wieder so ein sprachmonster ja
das ist es aber da komme ich wieder auf
meine alten Erfahrung die Frauen packt
die Pakistan die für große Schuhfirma
kleine Rohlinge zusammen näht und damit
drei Familien versorgt das ist die Frau
die da tatsächlich die Verantwortung
trägt und das Geld verdienen die Männer
sind fast alle arbeitslos das ist sehr
schwierig auch in Westafrika da war ich
auch viel unterwegs und da muss man sich
mal drauf konzentrieren die starken
Frauen gerade in den Entwicklungsländern
da müsste man mal gucken dass man die
wirklich mehr unterstützt dass die nicht
nur dort anerkannt sind aber was sondern
auch arbeiten aber was denkt da über zu
diesem Thema beispielsweise der SPD
Ortsverein Hagen der redet glaube ich
jetzt nicht über feministische aus dem
Politik und das war sozusagen der redet
lieber mit mir darüber ob man Krokus
macht oder ob man rot rot grün macht
oder irgendwas aber nee feministische
Außenpolitik ist schon natürlich
besser also glaube auch dass das ist
jetzt so erklärt aber gehen Sie mal zu
ihrem zu ihrer Bundestagsabgeordneten
die haben rechts nebenan sitzen der wird
Ihnen das gut erklären und ich glaube
ich glaube ich habe es auch verstanden
selbst
machen und dann reden wir hier bei 8:15
Uhr darüber wie sicher unsere Rente ist
wenn Sie gerne bei uns bis gleich wurden
sie abgezockt oder reingelegt das ist
also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt melden
unsere Reporter kümmern sich um ihren
falls Sie